le 1er septembre 10 729 un gréement
descend la garonne jusqu'à son
embouchure
une fois au large il prend la direction
des côtes africaines
bordeaux vient de basculer dans l'ère de
la traite
le premier bateau qui marque le début de
la traite négrière bordelaise de manière
constante s'appelle l'union
voilà donc il est parti en septembre 10
729 de bordeaux tout ce qui avait
précédé ceux de l'ordre des prémices
si l'union ouvre la voie aux négriers
bordelais leur négoce n'explose que dans
la seconde moitié du xviiie siècle
au total ce seront 130 mille esclaves
qui seront vendus par des armateurs
girondins toutefois bordeaux ne
dépassera jamais nantes premier port
négrier français
la traite négrière ça sera si j'ose dire
le second choix des négociants bordelais
parce que bordeaux a l'immense avantage
d'avoir un arrière pays très riche et
ils ont le vin dont la traite pour eux
c'est relativement accessoires etc
louis 15 c'est la royauté qui vraiment
insiste pour que les bordelais se
mettent à la faire la traite des noirs
et les bordelais reçoivent des
subventions
voilà jusqu'à la révolution française
ils touchent de l'argent tant de livres
partenaires de jauge tant de livres par
noir débarqué aux antilles et ça
évidemment ça va être un stimulant
extrêmement important
ce commerce triangulaire entre bordeaux
l'afrique et les antilles est encouragée
par l'état car il permet le
développement de comptoir et de
plantations dans les îles des caraïbes
les expéditions dure souvent plus d'une
année et ne se font jamais quel vide
dans ses cales
le vin est toujours là qui côtoie
d'autres marchandises
l'état-major du navire ne part jamais
120 le contrat qui est signée entre le
capitaine et l'armateur
il est bien stipulé que le capitaine ne
partira que si la des barris de bons
vins à disposition dans le navire en
même temps que du vin on embarque aussi
de la pacotille et des armes destinées à
être échangé en afrique contre des
esclaves
ces esclaves sont chargés comme de
vulgaires marchandises dans les cales où
ils ne peuvent même pas se tenir debout
une fois parvenus à saint domingue ou en
martinique
la cargaison humaine est remplacé par du
café du chocolat de l'indigo
les négociants bordelais rentabilise le
voyage et tiennent une comptabilité
sordide dans leur carnet de bord
le musée d'aquitaine possède plusieurs
de ses carnets ils témoignent de la vie
à bord et d'un quotidien en fait
d'horreur et d'inhumanité au clair de
lune le temps toujours le même à 11h03
qu'argent fit monter une assez jolie
négresse dans ma chambre je passais deux
heures avec elles et l'exploiter deux
fois c'était la première femme que
j'avais vu depuis mon départ de france
on tenait aussi une comptabilité
parallèle celle des esclaves morts
durant la traversée
nous voyons apparaître clairement
également une comptabilité macabre avec
un symbole apparaissant dans les marges
qui ne sont autres que des croix et à
chacune des croix qui apparaissent en
face est mentionné à chaque fois de
manière inéluctable et bien le décès
d'un esclave et principalement du
scorbut qui montre au delà des
conditions de traverser tout à fait
terrible et bien que les maladies les
mauvaises conditions de vie étaient bien
entendu sources d'une très forte
mortalité à l'intérieur de ces navires
négriers
lors de ces traversées la mortalité
pouvait toucher 30 % des hommes
embarqués
mais en vendant les survivants à bon
prix les marchands d'esclaves faisait
des gains substantiels
ce qui explique que des familles
bordelaises et gagner beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent
parmi ces familles les nérac
leur patronyme a traversé les siècles
un deuxième grand cru classé continue de
porter leur nom
[Musique]
c'est grâce au commerce colonial et
négriers que les nérac des protestons
régnèrent sur le port de bordeaux qui
dans la seconde moitié du xviiie siècle
est devenu le premier port d'europe
bordeaux devient l'entrepôt du commerce
de redistribution des produits coloniaux
vers l'europe
les nérac possède une flotte de huit
navires dont 3 négriers on estime leur
fortune à 2 millions de livres pour vous
donner un ordre de comparaison à
matelots qui va la traite ou en tout cas
à mathod de marine marchande gagne 25
livres par mois
l'envoyé 2 millions une fortune et un
salaire mensuel de 25 kg c'était l'homme
le plus riche de bordeaux
avec cet argent les nérac bâtisse en
1775 un imposant hôtel particulier
l'hôtel nérac se trouve au centre de
bordeaux et contribuer jusqu'à nos jours
à la splendeur de la capitale girondine
l'aîné raconte engage l architecte
bordelais le plus côté victor louis à
qui l'on doit le grand théâtre
un génie que s'arrachent alors les
fortunes locales
bordeaux à cette époque vit sans doute
ses heures les plus prospères
[Musique]
les richesses tirées du commerce
maritime et de la traite négrière
rejaillissent sur le vignoble en 1777
les nérac rachète un domaine à barsac
dans la région de sauternes
[Musique]
on y produit toujours un blanc liquoreux
classé si les nérac investissent au sud
de bordeaux et non dans le médoc c'est
qu'ils veulent édifier leur château le
long de la voie menant de bordeaux à
toulouse axe important du commerce afin
que leur demeure soit vue du plus grand
nombre et pour la rendre plus attrayante
ils vont cette fois se rappelle à
l'architecte andré mollier un
collaborateur de victor louis le château
nérac est né
dans un cadre de vie luxueux certes mais
discret en plein accord avec leur
austérité protestante les nérac aime
recevoir tisser des relations entretenir
leur position de grandes tables des
notables qui se rêve aristocrates et
qu'ils vont jouer de leur entregent pour
demander au roi des lettres de noblesse
demande refusée
les archives départementales de gironde
conserve la réponse royal les
motivations de celles ci peuvent
surprendre
en effet le refus n'est pas motivée par
l'ignominie de la traite négrière
mais par la religion des nérac ne sont
ils pas réformé voilà la réponse du
pouvoir royal à la demande de la longue
liste des frères miracle c'est un refus
refus est la raison d'ailleurs né en est
indiquée cependant monsieur je ne
saurais donné mon suffrage aussi en irak
c'est ça notre regret que je le refuse
mais la rpr la religion prétendue
réformée
quand ils forment profession me paraît
dans les principes notre constitution
former un obstacle puissant gros succès
de leurs désirs les frères en irak sont
protestants ils ne seront donc pas noble
les nérac ne seront jamais noble et les
vents abolitionnistes qui commence à
souffler vont balayer leur fortune
après la révolution l'esclavagé est
aboli une première fois les archives
nationales conserve ce décret symbolique
en 1794 la convention nationale déclare
que l'esclavagé des [__] dans toutes
les colonies est abolie en conséquence
elle décrète que tous les hommes sans
distinction de couleur domiciliés dans
les colonies sont citoyens français
bonaparte pour favoriser les intérêts
économiques des colonies va revenir en
1802 sur cette abolition
ce n'est qu'un demi siècle plus tard que
l' esclavage sera définitivement aboli
par l'article 6 de la constitution
une décennie plus tôt en 1837 la famille
nérac avait revendu son domaine